-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
Former President Trump
spent last night at Trump Tower
after appearing
at his civil fraud trial.
"It's good to be home,"
said Trump
as he walked into the courtroom.
[ Laughter ]
On the first day
of former President Trump's
civil fraud trial,
"The New York Post" reported
that a large takeout order
from McDonald's
was brought into the courthouse.
Wow.
I knew he was in trouble,
but I didn't know they were
seeking the death penalty.
[ Laughter ]
During the opening
of yesterday's trial,
former President Trump's lawyer
claimed that Trump's
Mar-a-Lago club would sell
for at least $1 billion.
Oh, I'm sure he could get that
just for what's in the shower.
[ Laughter ]
After Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz
filed a resolution
that would remove
Kevin McCarthy
from the speakership,
McCarthy tweeted, "Bring it on."
And Gaetz replied, "Just did."
You know, a lot of people think
Joe Biden is too old
to govern,
but it sounds like
these guys aren't old enough.
[ Laughter ]
After Matt Gaetz announced the
motion to remove Kevin McCarthy,
McCarthy said Gaetz has
"personal things in his life
that he has challenges with,"
like figuring out how
to set his Venmo to private.
[ Laughter ]
Hunter Biden was arraigned
in Delaware today
on federal gun charges.
We now go live
to the Fox News control room.
-[ Dramatic music plays ]
-[ All cheering ]
♪♪
You know, I'm happy for 'em.
They've had a --
They've had a rough time
recently.
It's nice they get
a little light.
Justice Clarence Thomas
yesterday
recused himself from
a Supreme Court decision
for the first time,
not because he had
a conflict of interest --
just because he had
a fishing trip planned.
And it would have been rude
to cancel
'cause someone else paid for it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you'd cancel
on a wealthy friend?!
A wealthy friend would fly you
private to a fishing trip
and you would cancel?
I think not!
This poor ma--
You judge this poor man?
A pauper?!
[ Laughter ]
A pauper who can only fish
if a wealthy patron fly --
And you judge him.
Shame!
Jury selection began today
in the trial against
disgraced FTX CEO
Sam Bankman-Fried,
which is surprising
'cause by the looks of him,
he already got
the electric chair.
[ Laughter ]
"No, he's still ali--
It didn't take."
The fast-food chain Taco Bell
announced today
that it will add breakfast tacos
to its menu for the first time.
Finally, some good news for
people who wake up still drunk.
[ Laughter ]
[Slurring]
"Yeah, I'll get a taco."
[ Laughter ]
Archaeologists in Spain believe
they have found
the oldest footwear
ever discovered in Europe.
So congratulations
to an American dad on vacation.
[ Laughter ]
The first public beach
in Manhattan opened yesterday,
and I feel like it's gonna
be hard to tell who's sunbathing
and who just washed up there.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, Johnny Three Fingers!
Enjoying the beach?
Johnny?"
[ Laughter ]
A woman in Chicago
recently went skydiving
at the age of 104.
And if you're wondering
what was up with her parachute,
those were her breasts.
[ Laughter ]
We have a writer
named Mike Scollins
who wrote that joke, and --
Yeah, you've heard of him.
You heard of him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bad guy. Good writer.
I always say,
"You're a good writer.
Why don't you write for good?"
He's from Boston.
He's from Massachusetts and all.
He gives you a hard time.
You tell him you don't
like his jokes, he's like...
It's just better to let it go.
He goes, "Do you get it?"
I go, "I get it."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, last night's
Powerball jackpot --
I can't believe
Scollins got applause.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nothing's worse --
[ Applause ]
Nothing worse
than trying to shame a guy
and find out he has fans!
And, finally, last night's
Powerball jackpot
reached
an estimated $1.2 billion...
or as Trump's accountant
calls it, $35 billion.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.